I feel like I'm in a 70s porn right
today we're at the Hollywood Roosevelt
trying on competitive swimsuits these
are the same ones that like Michael
Phelps Ryan Lochte all those guys where
I have a feeling it's gonna be a bit of
a struggle I'm a big dude so I'm
expecting some flats to kind of like
spill over I fully expect to put on the
swimsuit and become a mermaid I read
about the swimsuit and it says that it
constricts your muscles so I don't know
how that actually helps you swim faster
but we'll find out today
my suit and this is may my arm not my
leg my arm this is one of my legs just a
wow this doesn't feel stretchy at all
like a Superman outfit here we go this
is really hard I cannot get this over my
ass this isn't going anywhere so we
might need scissors my butt is just way
too big to like put anything over that
just leave me here to die I'm done I'm
losing circulation from my knees down I
want my mom
throwing in the towel I'm giving up I
tried for 35 minutes it ain't happening
I'm having trouble breathing
can't wait to get this off it was stuck
trying to get over my ass for about 30
minutes at that point it just ripped
feels like it's gonna pop off it any
second so glad I ripped it because I can
breathe on one part of my body now I
feel like kinda like Captain America
right now like I look great right let's
go race
overall the experience was memorable and
miserable honestly like you could make a
Saw movie out of all of us trying to put
on these suits felt like I was colliding
through the water as opposed to like
fighting my way through it I bow down to
Olympic swimmers truly they're my heroes
now